[Music]
I have a question for you are you
religious please raise your hand right
now if you think of yourself as a
religious person okay let's see I'd say
about three or four percent I had no
idea there were so many believers at a
TED conference okay here's another
question do you think of yourself as
spiritual in any way shape or form raise
your hand okay that's the majority my
talk today is about the main reason or
one of the main reasons why most people
consider themselves to be spiritual in
some way shape or form my talk today is
about self transcendence it's just a
basic fact about being human that
sometimes the self seems to just melt
away and when that happens the feeling
is ecstatic and we reach for metaphors
of up and down to explain these feelings
we talk about being uplifted or elevated
now it's really hard to think about
anything abstract like this without a
good concrete metaphor so here's the
metaphor I'm offering today think about
the mind as being like a house with many
rooms most of which were very familiar
with but sometimes it's as though a
doorway appears from out of nowhere and
it opens onto a staircase we climb the
staircase and experience a state of
altered consciousness in 1902 the great
American psychologist William James
wrote about the many varieties of
religious experience he collected all
kinds of case studies he quoted the
words of all kinds of people who had a
variety of these experiences one of the
most exciting to me is this young man
Steven Bradley had an encounter he
thought with Jesus in 1820 and here's
what Bradley said about
I thought I saw the Savior in human
shape for about one second in the room
with arms extended appearing to say to
me come the next day I rejoiced with
trembling my happiness was so great that
I said I wanted to die this world had no
place in my affections previous to this
time I was very selfish and
self-righteous but now I desired the
welfare of all mankind and could with a
feeling heart forgive my worst enemies
so note how Bradley's petty moralistic
self just dies on the way up the
staircase and on this higher level he
becomes loving and forgiving the world's
many religions have found so many ways
to help people climb the staircase some
shut down the South using meditation
others use psychedelic drugs this is a
from a 16th century Aztec scroll showing
a man about to eat a psilocybin mushroom
and at the same moment get yanked up the
staircase by a God others use dancing
spinning and circling to promote self
transcendence but you don't need a
religion to get you through the
staircase lots of people find self
transcendence in nature others overcome
their self at raves but here's the
weirdest place of all war so many books
about war say the same thing that
nothing brings people together like war
and that bringing them together opens up
the possibility of extraordinary self
transcendent experiences I'm going to
play for you an excerpt from this book
by Glenn gray gray was a soldier in the
American army in World War two and after
the war he interviewed a lot of other
soldiers and wrote about the experience
of men in battle here's a key passage
where he basically describes the
staircase
many veterans will admit that the
experience of communal effort in battle
has been the high point of their lives
I passes insensibly into a week my
becomes hour an individual fate who
loses its central importance I believe
that it is nothing less than the
assurance of immortality that makes
self-sacrifice at these moments so
relatively easy I may fall but I do not
die for that which is real and me goes
forward and lives on in the comrades for
whom I gave up my life so what all of
these cases have in common is that the
self seems to thin out or melt away and
it feels good it feels really good in a
way totally unlike anything we feel in
our normal lives it feels somehow
uplifting this idea that we move up was
central in the writing of the great
French sociologist Emile Durkheim
Durkheim even called us homo duplex or
two-level man the lower level he called
the level of the profane now profane is
the opposite of sacred it just means
ordinary or common and in our ordinary
lives we exist as individuals we want to
satisfy our individual desires we pursue
our individual goals but sometimes
something happens that triggers a phase
change individuals unite into a team a
movement or a nation which is far more
than the sum of its parts
Durkheim called this level the level of
the sacred because he believed that the
function of religion was to unite people
into a group into a moral community
Durkheim believed that anything that
unites us takes on an air of sacredness
and once people surf all around some
sacred object or value they'll then work
as a team and fight to defend it
Durkheim wrote about a set of intense
collective emotions that accomplish this
miracle of the pluribus unum of making a
group out of part of individuals think
of the collective joy in Britain on the
day World War two ended think of the
collective anger
in Tahrir Square which brought down a
dictator and think of the collective
grief in the United States that we all
felt that brought us all together after
9/11 so let me summarize where we are
I'm saying that the capacity for self
transcendence is just a basic part of
being human I'm offering the metaphor of
a staircase in the mind I'm saying we
are homo duplex and this staircase takes
us up from the profane level to the
level of the sacred when we climb that
staircase self-interest fades away would
become just much less self-interested
and we feel as though we are better
nobler and somehow uplifted so here's
the million-dollar question for social
scientists like me is the staircase a
feature of our evolutionary design is it
a product of natural selection like our
hands or is it a bug a mistake in the
system is just this religious stuff it's
just something that happens when the
wires cross in the brain and that's you
know Jill has a stroke and she has this
religious experience it's just a mistake
well many scientists who study religion
take this view the new atheists for
example argue that religion is a set of
memes sort of parasitic memes to get
inside our minds and make us do all
kinds of crazy religious stuff
self-destructive stuff like suicide
bombing and after all how could it ever
be good for us to lose ourselves how
could it ever be adaptive for any
organism to overcome self-interest well
let me show you in the descent of man
Charles Darwin wrote a great deal about
the evolution of morality where did it
come from why do we have it
Darwin noted that many of our virtues
were very little used to ourselves but
there have great use to our groups he
wrote about the scenario in which two
tribes of early humans would have come
in contact and competition he said if
the one tribe included a great number of
courageous sympathetic and faithful
members who were always ready to aid and
defend each other
this tribe would succeed better and
conquer the other he went on to say that
selfish and contentious people will not
go here and without coherence nothing
can be affected in other words Charles
Darwin believed in group selection now
this idea has been very controversial
for the last 40 years but it's about to
make a major comeback this year
especially after Leo Wilson's book comes
out in April making a very strong case
that we and several other species are
products of group selection but really
the way to think about this is as
multi-level selection so look at it this
way you've got competition going on
within groups and across groups so
here's a group of guys on a college crew
team within this team there's
competition there guys competing with
each other the slowest rowers the
weakest rowers are going to get cut from
the team and only a few of these guys
are going to go on in this sport maybe
one of them will make it to the Olympics
so within the team their interests are
actually pitted against each other and
sometimes it would be advantageous for
one one of these guys to try to sabotage
the other guys
maybe he'll badmouth his chief rival to
the coach but while that competition is
going on within the boat this
competition is going on across boats and
once you put these guys in a boat
competing with another boat now they've
got no choice but to cooperate because
they're all in the same boat they can
only win if they all pull together as a
team I mean these things sound trite but
they are deep evolutionary truths the
main argument against group selection
has always been that well sure it would
be nice to have a group of co-operators
but as soon as you have a group of
co-operators they're just gonna get
taken over by Free Riders some
individuals that are going to exploit
the hard work of the others let me
illustrate this for you suppose we've
got a group of little organisms they can
be bacteria they can be hamsters it
doesn't matter what and let's suppose
that this little group here they evolved
to be cooperative well that's great they
graze they defend each other they work
together they generate wealth and as
you'll see in the simulation as they
interact they gain points as it were
they grow
and when they've doubled in size you'll
see them split and that's how they
reproduce and the population grows but
suppose then that one of them mutates
there's a mutation in the gene and one
of them mutates to follow a selfish
strategy it takes advantage of the
others and so when a green interacts
with the blue you'll see the green gets
larger and the blue gets smaller so
here's how things play out we start with
just one green and as it interacts it
gains wealth or points or food and in
short order the co-operators are done
for the Free Riders have taken over if a
group cannot solve the free rider
problem then it cannot reap the benefits
of cooperation and group selection
cannot get started but there are
solutions to the free rider problem it's
not that hard a problem in fact Nature
has solved it many many times and
nature's favorite solution is to put
everyone in the same boat for example
why is it that the mitochondria in every
cell has its own DNA totally separate
from them from the DNA in the nucleus
it's because they used to be separate
free living bacteria and they came
together and became a super organism
somehow or other maybe once swallowed
another we'll never know exactly why but
once they got a membrane around them
they were all in the same membrane now
all the wealth created the division of
labor all the greatness created by
cooperation stays locked inside the
membrane and we've got a super organism
and now let's rerun the simulation
putting one of these super organisms
into a population of free riders of
defectors of cheaters and look what
happens a super organism can basically
take what it wants it's so big and
powerful and efficient that it can take
resources from the Greens from the
defectors the cheaters and pretty soon
the whole population is actually
composed of these new super organisms
what I've shown you here is sometimes
called a major transition in
evolutionary history Darwin's laws don't
change but now there's a new kind of
player on the field and things begin to
look very different now this transition
was not a one-time freak of nature that
just happened with some
tyria it happened again about a hundred
and twenty or hundred and forty million
years ago when some solitary wasps began
creating little simple primitive nests
or hives once several wasps were all
together in the same hive they had no
choice but to cooperate because pretty
soon they were locked into competition
with other hives and the most cohesive
hives one just as Darwin said these
early wasps gave rise to the bees and
the and the ants that have covered the
world and changed the biosphere and it
happened again even more spectacularly
in the last half million years when our
own ancestors became cultural creatures
they came together around a hearth or a
campfire
they divided labor they began painting
their bodies they spoke their own
dialects and eventually they worshiped
their own gods once they were all in the
same tribe they could keep the benefits
of cooperation locked inside and they
unlocked the most powerful force ever
known on this planet which is human
cooperation a force for construction and
destruction of course human groups are
nowhere near as cohesive as bee hives
human groups may look like hives for
brief moments but they tend to then
break apart we're not locked into
cooperation the way bees and ants are in
fact often as as we've seen happen a lot
of the Arab Spring revolts often those
divisions are along religious lines
nonetheless when people do come together
and put themselves all into the same
movement they can move mountains look at
the people in these photos I've been
showing you do you think they're they're
pursuing their self-interest or are they
pursuing communal interest which
requires them to lose themselves and
become simply a part of a whole ok so
that was my talk delivered in the
standard Ted way and now I'm gonna give
the whole talk over again in three
minutes in a more full-spectrum sort of
way
we humans have many varieties of
religious experience as William James
one of the most common is climbing the
secret staircase and losing ourselves
the staircase takes us for the
experience of life as profane or
ordinary upwards to the experience of
life is sacred or deeply interconnected
we are Homo du Plessis as Durkheim and
we are Homo duplex because we evolved by
multi-level selection as Darwin
explained I can't be certain that the
staircase is an adaptation rather than
above but if it is an adaptation then
the implications are profound if it is
an adaptation then we evolved to be
religious I don't mean that we evolved
to join gigantic organized religions
those things came along too recently I
mean that we evolved to see sacredness
all around us and to join with others
two teams that circle of sacred objects
people and ideas this is why politics is
so tribal politics is partly profane
it's partly about self-interest but
politics is also about sacredness
it's about joining with others to pursue
moral ideals it's about the eternal
struggle between good and evil and we
all believe were on the good team and
most importantly
if the staircase is removed it explains
the persistent undercurrent of
dissatisfaction in life because human
beings are to some extent
Piyush creatures like bees where bees
were busted out of the hive during the
Enlightenment - we broke down the old
institutions and brought Liberty to the
oppressed we unleashed earth changing
creativity and generated vast welcome
nowadays we fly around like individual
bees exulting in our freedom but
sometimes we wonder is this all there is
what should I do with my life what's
missing what's missing is that we are
homo duplex but modern secular society
was built to satisfy our lower profane
cells it's really comfortable down here
on the lower level come have a seat in
my home entertainment center one great
challenge of modern life is to find the
staircase amid all the clutter and then
to do something good and know that once
you climb to the dome I see this desire
in my students at the University of
Virginia they all want to find a cause
or call that they can throw themselves
into they're all searching for their
staircase and that gives me hope because
people are not purely selfish most
people long to overcome pettiness and
become part of something
and this explains the extraordinary
resonance of this simple metaphor
conjured up nearly 400 years ago no man
is an island entire of itself every man
is a piece of the continent a part of
the main thank you
you
[Music]